void mads I'll throw this first question
to you because one of my favorite things
about Indiana Jones movies is seeing
familiar like elements and ideas come
back so when you're playing an indie
villain is there anything you've seen in
a past Indie bad guy that you wanted a
whole tie to but then I also want the
opposite something that made your
characters uniquely your own
okay they're all they're all they're not
too kooky they're not too um you know
twist the uh the mustache yeah
those are like a framework in the
Indiana Jones what the Paramus is fairly
white you can you can stretch that
you've seen that before but there's also
a reality sense that you have to be
honest to it's very hard to put a finger
on but but you know what it is when you
see it it's like this belongs or this
doesn't belong right but we can't put a
finger on it something about it whenever
I turn on one of these movies and it has
those qualities feels like I'm coming
home there's like an inherent warmth in
it and I love it Shawna for you if I had
my choice and I could have a prequel to
this movie I would want agent Mason's
story is there any backstory detail you
came up with on your own for her that
maybe we don't see or hear about in the
movie but we could feel informing your
performance and the choices she makes
yeah I think um the fact that she's this
young black woman that she was able to
kind of blend in a little bit with the
the younger um
um Community
um in New York especially how she has
this Edge uh maybe she was recruited to
to do a little bit of a cointel pro or
something but then got assigned to this
um situation and maybe he's
um initially already frustrated with
that and in the end of the lack of um
respect that she's she's been able to
glean from these guys knowing that
there's a lot of tension with the
ideology and racism and all these things
um so that was just got a little bit of
something that I put in there for myself
I get Mighty obsessed with backstory I
would very much like that backstory on
screen I know you're on the set of black
panther but was there anything about
jumping into a big franchise film in a
more significant role like this that you
know made you stand there and go like my
God I can't believe this is what it
takes to bring a character like this to
screen in a big franchise movie like
this oh yeah I mean the journey was was
incredible uh just from the fittings and
the fine tuning of of this jacket as
opposed to that jacket and the length of
hair and in this in this way or the
thrill being a little bit longer
um and then getting to my first day on
set and it was out in Glasgow and
exterior just a big sweeping I mean the
fact that they were able to turn Glasgow
into New York 1969 was just wonderful I
feel like this is just so many
incredibly Talent did people involved in
this process and all I have to do is
just like kind of walk here say this
line ignore this guy flip open a little
pad and you know what I mean it's just
like oh this is this is
insane but you know it's just that so
much work has gone into these intimate
moments in these in these uh the uh the
relationship with these characters so
yeah it was surreal for sure I'll throw
that question to both of you now as well
because you just brought up tiny details
and the importance of them is there any
teeny tiny detail whether it's something
in the production design costume design
a personal choice you made that you know
might not be front and center in a frame
but you knew was really important to
filling out this world yeah well I was
kind of Jim said Jim said I didn't want
to offend me but I have a role for you
and read it and then we'll talk and then
I read it and I was like man I'm the bad
guy that sucks I want to be I want to be
the good guy but you have to make these
characters work and on you know on the
screen my character's uh you know he's a
lap dog to to mess his character and
he's and that may seem very simple but
to me I'm trying to wrap my head around
why would a guy be affiliated with this
party and then just going in deeper and
finding out well he's not really
accepted in anywhere and this is really
the only club or tribe that will accept
him so
you know going not so much with the
ideology but just more of the acceptance
and that's my loyalty to to mess his
character and I think that's what kept
me in in in him didn't expect to get a
heartbreaking backstory for him yeah
believe it yeah a lot of therapy after
this
boy I'm working with it I don't know I
mean there's a lot of things that you do
and it might not end up but it might
just be in the back of your head when
you're doing I was I think I was trying
to make this character
nervous to degree when he was not uh the
boss of the room and the second he was
the boss of the room he wasn't nervous
at all uh so like just go back and forth
with that and see how that played out
like a man who wasn't completely secure
all the time
I'm not sure it comes across but that's
ready
for all three of you now review now is
watching the the press conference you
Dan and somebody Harrison had brought up
really caught my ear he was emphasizing
that all the actors on this set gave
more to he to each other than he had
ever really seen before so can you each
pinpoint a time when another cast member
gave to you when you needed it most it
was my birthday on set
um and uh Phoebe got me a cake
and a little uh card you know she plays
for the deck of cards in the film and it
gave me a little card I think it's the
Queen of Hearts uh and then
um a drawing illustration of my
character
um and it was wonderful like it you know
you have to work in your birthday it can
be a kind of love hate relationship
where you're like I'm in all day and I'm
at work I would rather be whatever but I
think everyone
um crew as well just decorating it was
just really lovely and then again TV
with the cake and everything so I really
felt like you know I was being
celebrated and I was touching
heaven for you too uh well shortly right
to you so can we spoil a lot there's a
scene
but she kinds of doesn't make it out of
their life
anyways uh so you shoot that again and
again and again all right and then
camera eventually turns around and it's
my turn and this is what it's all about
that you're still doing the same thing
you're still
acting out you still you know throwing
that disbelief towards me every time and
this is a this is what we want from each
other it's not always the case but the I
think we did it 20 times we kept going
now with tearing up in your eyes even
though you were off screen this is what
it's all about can you stop that boy I
don't know if I could talk that
um just the memory of you know Harris
and welcoming
being truly felt like you're welcome
here we love what you do you're you're
as important as we are I think that
um just makes a really good place to to
make good work and Harrison has always
shown that he's um
he's not uh the star who's on his
trailer all the time he's I don't know
he's just like your dad hanging out he's
just there I'm a big believer Good Vibes
like that radiate off screen in the
final product that I think they do here
congratulations on the movie